-I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
stoner stories from you guys.
Here, this first one's
from @Duffield.
She says...
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-It was a roll --
It was a stick.
-It was Secret.
It's a secret.
-Roll-on deodorant, too,
yeah.
This one is from @petegaden.
He said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You're b-a-a-a-ad!
[ Laughter ]
-This one's
from @Jimsensei2112.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's
from @freakinpirate.
-Oh, that guy.
[ Light laughter ]
-He says...
[ Laughter ]
There you go.
"Two, three..."
[ Laughter ]
This one's
from @DismukeKaitlyn.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from
@AmandoAlexander.
She says...
Oh, that's --
[ Audience groans ]
-Oh.
-This one's
from @breezeplayer.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
At least she didn't see it.
She'd be really freaked out.
-"Aah!"
-This last one's from @ibyellow.
She says...
There you go!
That's all we have for our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.